(upbeat music)
- It's a great pleasure to be allowed
to introduce professor Lewontin.
He is an old friend and my former
post doctoral supervisor from my time
at the University of Chicago.
Professor Lewontin,
as you heard yesterday Professor Lewontin
received his undergraduate
degree from Harvard
and then a master's and PhD
from Columbia University
where he was a student
with Theodosius Dobzhansky.
He then held faculty positions
at North Carolina State University,
the University of Rochester,
and then the University of
Chicago before moving to Harvard
to become Alexander Agassiz
Professor of Zoology.
In addition to the great many honors
that were mentioned yesterday,
Professor Lewontin was elected
to the National Academy of Science in 1967
and then resigned the
National Academy in 1973.
Now Dick Lewontin has
really had two careers,
one career as an evolutionary geneticist
and another as a public
spokesman for science.
As an evolutionary geneticist
he's made major contributions
to both the theory of
evolutionary genetics
and to its experimental study.
He was among the first to use computers
as tools for simulation.
He was among the first to use the tools
of modern molecular
biology to study genetic
variation in natural populations.
In 1974, he wrote a book entitled
The Genetic Basis of Evolutionary Change
which really defined the research program
in evolutionary genetics ever since.
As a public spokesman for science,
he has entered I think
every major controversy
involving genetics and evolution.
If he hasn't, it was only an oversight.
(audience laughing)
As a result he
entered the controversy over sociobiology,
over the use of genetically
modified organisms,
over race and IQ, over
large-scale genomic projects,
and many other controversies.
In these areas he has
always been provocative,
controversial, and stubborn.
And it's a great pleasure today
to introduce him to speak
on one of these topics.
His title is, The Concept
of Race: The Confusion
of Social and Biological Reality.
Dick.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks very much, Monty.
I only want to make one
correction to your introduction
and that is the notion
that I ever supervised you
is a very extraordinary one.
(audience laughing)
We worked together for a while
but I certainly never supervised him.
The lecture today is rather different
from the one I gave yesterday.
The one I gave yesterday
was largely impressionistic,
if you like, and heuristic.
Today I'm gonna bombard you with numbers.
I'm sorry about that.
Those of you who hate numbers,
perhaps you should leave now.
But the subject of race
as a biological concept
cannot be dealt with except numerically.
Quantitatively, that is to say,
and the best way I know
to do it is with numbers.
So I should warn you about that,
that it may in some ways
be a disappointment to you,
and I regret that, but I
don't know how else to do it
with intellectual honesty.
The question of race is a curious one.
The classification and
denomination of others
as belonging to different races
is, of course, not a uniquely American
or European phenomenon.
The Japanese have their
notions about race.
Indeed, the word race
has had many meanings.
We speak, for example, of someone being
the last of his race, and what we mean
is the last member of his family.
Or the human race at the other extreme,
which means the entire species.
So that race, which
comes from the root root,
means what that person sprang from.
And the notion that we
understand who we are
and others belong to a different kind,
a different race, seems
to be if not universal,
because I don't know
enough about what everybody
in the world or every culture thinks,
seems to be extraordinarily widespread.
And I've tried to understand that
and I think we should
all try to begin with
to ask ourselves why is it
that the concept of race,
the division of the world
between us and them,
whoever us happens to be
and them happens to be,
why that is so common historically
and culturally and geographically.
I would like to make a
couple of suggestions.
They're only suggestions.
One is, of course,
that one is constantly,
certainly in the history
of the human species
and in the early history
but still true, there is a kind of
if I may call it nationalism
or localism or villagism
or tribalism, whatever you wanna call it.
That is to say, a group that
has solidarity living together
which deals with other groups
that have their own solidarity
often in a hostile and contradictory way,
and so there's the constant reiteration of
the within our group as
opposed to as against those,
and that occurs at the village level
in people in the Amazon.
It occurs at the national level in Europe
and everything in between.
So that constant struggle
between the group
of which you are a member,
in which you have some
economic, social, marital,
other kinds of religious ties
as against somebody else
already creates a separation
between them and us.
That seems obvious.
But the other thing which is
perhaps not quite so obvious
is that the concept that
there exists other races
comes in great part from our perception
of the variation among people in the world
and the variation that we know
among those people with
whom we are brought up.
To illustrate that I'll tell a story
which my wife will tell
me is not quite accurate
but it's what we call
(speaks in foreign language).
I mean, it's close enough.
She and I were in in Egypt, upper Egypt,
years and years ago, and
we were in a large hotel
and a man came up to her and started
to talk to her volubly
about something in Egyptian.
And she kept saying, no, no,
you've got the wrong person.
I mean, I'm sorry, I really don't know
what you're talking about.
I don't know what this incident is.
And he kept at it and kept at it
and she kept insisting that
no, no, he'd made a mistake.
And finally he stepped back and said
oh, I'm terribly sorry, but
you all look alike to me.
And this notion that you all look alike
but we all look different is a consequence
of our acculturation, our
walking down the street,
our understanding of who is whom.
I mean, again, to make it personal
my wife and I often play a game.
We walk down the street in Cambridge,
which is a very cosmopolitan community,
unlike Berkeley, of course.
(audience laughing)
And we walk behind people
and I put my elbow there
and I say, French.
And she'll say, German.
And then we walk a little faster
in order to catch up with them
to hear what they're saying
and one of us is right
usually, or the other.
That is to say, the very
motions of their bodies,
the way in which they move their faces
and lips and hands, their
total physical appearance
tells us that they are not Americans
and even gives us hints
about what they are.
My greatest triumph in this respect,
which I'm very proud of, is that once
we were in the desert in California
and on the top of a knoll very far away,
I mean, twice as far as
the back of this room
was a group of young people
who were talking to each other volubly.
You couldn't hear a syllable
that they were saying.
And I said they are
French, and I was right.
(audience laughing)
So you you must take account of the fact
that there are local differences
in every aspect of culture
including body appearance
and carriage and so on
of which we are not ordinarily conscious
until we confront people who
come from someplace else.
And the result of that has been
that you all look different
but they all look alike.
And that is a consequence
of that acculturation.
Now the question I wanna talk about today
is really what is it we
know in some objective sense
about the variation among human beings
that corresponds or does not correspond
to that perception that
we all look different
and we recognize each other instantly
but they all look alike.
And what can we say about that?
Because, of course, it has
immense political consequences.
Once you agree that we are all different
but they are all alike,
you also have a way of
handling the problem
of colonizing them, enslaving them,
dealing with them in
all kinds of demeaning,
and ways of asymmetric power
because they're all alike anyway.
And that, in a sense, dehumanizes them.
But part of that dehumanizing process
is not just that they don't look like us
but they are all alike.
They can be objectified.
They belong to a race,
and once I know that
I know all about them.
That's all I need to know.
Whereas, of course, if
I say they're Europeans
or Americans or something
then that doesn't help me much
because, after all, we're all different.
So the reason this talk
will be so numerical
is precisely because we
need to ask the question
how variable are human
beings within groups
and between groups,
within those people who speak Swedish
as opposed to those who
are Kikuyu or whatever.
How much objective reality is there
to the claim that I just discussed
about differences within
and between groups?
And, of course, to say
objective means obviously
to ask about genes, because
nothing else is objective, so...
(audience chuckling)
Well, I mean, I have to apologize for that
because the last lecture
downplayed the importance of genes
but genes have one advantage to us,
and that is we can actually characterize
without any prejudice the
DNA sequences of organisms
and we can ask questions like
how much of the variation in DNA sequences
exists among the people
who live in Denmark
as opposed to the
difference on the average
between Danes and Ewe.
I mean, we can ask that question
and that question has some relevance.
Although it's not completely probative,
it has some relevance to
asking questions like,
do we expect that all
the people in Denmark
will be smarter than all
the people in South Africa.
And that's because we
believe that genes tell us
something about people.
So I want to deal with this
issue on a quantitative basis.
I want to ask the question,
putting perception aside
and the way in which we
learn to distinguish people
one from another,
what can we say about
actual genetic differences
between individuals, between groups,
within populations, between populations,
what do we know about the geography
of human biology and what does that tell
us about the concept of race
and how do we have to cope with that
when we deal with what is a reality?
Race is, look, I want to make it clear
and I tried to make it clear in my title.
Race is a reality.
It is a social reality and everybody knows
it's a social reality.
The issue is what is the relationship
between that social reality,
that social allocation
of individuals to groups,
and anything we can say
about their biology.
So I speak as a biologist
rather than a sociologist,
because there's no question
about the social reality of race.
Now what I wanna do is to go through
some evidence about how many,
how much difference there is
within and between human groups
and then discuss what the processes are
that modulate that variation
and why it looks the way it,
probably looks the way it does,
and what we might expect even
in the future in that respect.
So I guess, Ellen, you gotta help me here.
I can't get on without Ellen.
I wanna show you a slide
which is sort of typical.
It's gonna take me a minute to explain it,
it but you're stuck with it.
This is a diagram having to do
with human ABO blood groups.
You all know your ABO blood group.
You probably know what group you are
whether you're AB, or B, or O.
And this is a so-called trilineal diagram,
and it gives the proportion
of the gene allele A,
the proportion B, and the proportion O
at the genic level,
so they add up at 100%.
And it gives the proportion of that
in a particular population.
And what I have done is plot
on this little triangular diagram
the location in this kind of
funny three-dimensional space.
Although it really looks
like two dimensions,
it's really got three dimensions in it.
Frequency of I, frequency of the O allele,
the A allele and the B allele,
plot various human populations.
And then I've drawn little
circles around clusters.
This is a cluster here.
There's a cluster here.
And the first question I wanted to ask is,
I mean, this is just
typical of what we'll see.
Is there any geographical or
racial meaning to the clusters?
Let's say if you belong
in the same cluster
is it because you're all Europeans
or you're all Africans?
So these are different populations.
And let me give you an example.
This cluster here consists
of population two,
eight, 10, 13, and 20.
Population two is an African population.
Eight and 13 are Asian
populations, 20 are Europeans.
So Europeans, Asians, and Africans
all clustered together in
this one little cluster here.
Here's another cluster made
of three, four, and five.
And number three are Africans,
and four and five are Native Americans.
So this kind of thing
is disturbing already.
I'm just trying to give you an example.
Genetically disturbing to the notion
that there are clear
differences between populations.
Okay, this is just an introduction
to the general question
and the general approach.
No, I don't need the next one quite yet.
We need to know a few facts
about the human species
and its genetics which are relevant.
First of all, human beings
are immensely variable genetically.
The people in this room, one from another,
the person next to you differs
by about three million
nucleotides from you.
Three million.
Now that's not very many considering
that you have three billion nucleotides,
but nevertheless there are
three million nucleotides
on the average between any
two people in this room.
And by the way, that's
true whether the person
sitting next to you you think belongs
to the same race as you or not.
There isn't much difference,
as it'll turn out,
but three million nucleotides different.
Something like 25% of all
genes of known function
that produce known
enzymes of various kinds
are what we call polymorphic in humans.
That is to say, there
exists more than one form
of that gene, like the ABO blood groups,
which there is A, B, and O.
So about a quarter of all the genes
that anybody's ever looked
at are variable in this way,
so that some percent of the
population has one variant
and another percent of
the population has another
and another and another.
So 25% of your genes belong
to the variable class.
Third, something on the order of 10%
of all your genes
you got a different form
of it from your mother
than from your father.
You're what is called a heterozygous.
You've got two different allelic forms.
So about 10% of your genes
are already different from one another
in the two copies that your got from.
And that makes humans pretty
typical of species in general.
I mean, for fruit flies
that I know more about,
the numbers are a third
of them are polymorphic,
12% are polymorphic, or
you got a different one
from one parent and the other.
But human beings are
sort of typical animals
in this respect.
They're very variable genetically,
and every one of you is very different
in 10% of your genes,
or different in 10% of genes
of the gene you got from
your mother and your father.
Now that's the first thing
we have to understand,
this huge amount of genetic variation.
Now because there is this huge amount
of genetic variation,
we are able to ask a question, which is,
if you are different from the
person sitting next to you
because of these variable genes,
how much more different are you
if you have ancestors from completely
different parts of the world
than if you have ancestors who came
from the same part of the world?
If both your ancestors were Swedes,
does that mean you're much more similar
than if one of your ancestors
was a Swede and the other one was Chinese?
That's a question we can ask objectively.
The second, and one thing we do know
and I wanna make this
clear from the beginning,
we do not know of any gene,
no one has ever found a gene,
I'm not saying they don't exist,
but in all the searching no
one has ever found a gene
in which one so-called race
has 100% of one form of the gene
and some other race has 100%
of another form of the gene.
There are no single
genes that differentiate
Africans from Asians,
Asians from Europeans,
Europeans from from Australian
Aborigines, and so on.
And the second slide I want to show you
are the most extremely
different genes that we know of
between the classical races.
And by the way, for a lot of the time
when I talk about race
I'm going along with a gag.
Asians are one race,
Africans are another race,
Europeans are another race,
Australian Aborigines are another race,
Polynesians are another race.
I'm gonna talk a lot about that problem,
how you decide, because you can't ask
how much difference there is between races
until you tell me how
you know what a race is
and who's in it.
I mean, do the people of India belong
to the same race that we do?
If they don't then the
answer will be different
than if they do, so we have that problem.
Here are three genes,
the Duffy blood group,
the Rhesus blood group, and the P factor
for which there are greater differences
between the classical races.
They even have these classical names,
Caucasoid, Negroid, and
Mongoloid, whatever.
What they mean is white,
yellow, and black, I guess.
What they mean is people from
Africa, people from Europe,
and people from the mainland of Asia.
And you see that there
are huge differences
in the frequency of the
three forms of this gene,
the Duffy blood group.
Caucasoids only have 3% of FY
and roughly 50/50 numbers of these two
whereas people from Africa are 94% FY
and that's gonna turn out
to be very useful to us
in asking some questions,
and only 6% of FYA.
And the Mongoloids are only 9% of this
and 90% of this.
So you see huge differentiation
in this particular gene
between these major groups, okay?
That's a maximum.
But notice it is not the case
that Africans are 100% of one thing
and Mongoloids are 100% of another.
There's always overlap,
and that's an extreme
point I want to make.
We don't know of any gene
which is race distinguishing.
Here are three genes
which, on the contrary,
show extreme similarity
in frequencies of the variant types.
The Auberger factor, 62 to 38, 65 to 35.
I don't have the data for for Asians.
XG, 2/3 to 1/3, 55 to
45, 55 to 40, and so on.
So I put these up to give
you the outside limits
of what we know.
Some genes you can't
distinguish by frequency at all
between major groups,
but there are a few genes
in which there are big differences.
But that's about all you can say.
But I do want to emphasize,
again, I've said it three times
but I'm gonna say it again.
We do not know of any gene which,
if you've got it you're certainly,
I mean, that distinguishes you 100%
from some other so-called racial group.
Okay, now we could dispense with that.
Now what I wanna do is to ask the question
which I began with, how much variation
between individuals lies
within local populations,
how much of it lies between populations
belonging to the same what
we call classical race,
and how much of it comes between races.
Now to ask that question
you have to define these
races to begin with.
I can't ask how much genetic difference
is there between races until I decide
who's in what race.
And that turns out to be not so easy.
For example, are the
Turks Asians or Europeans?
Well you see, they speak
a Central Asian language
but they look like Europeans to me.
Are the Urdu and Hindi-speaking people
of the Indian subcontinent,
are they belong to the Caucasians
or should they have their
own group or are they Asians?
What about the people of the Pacific,
the Islanders of the Pacific, and so on.
Each one presents certain
contrasts linguistically
and physically.
The Finns are a real pain in the neck
because nobody could look
more washed out European than a Finn,
but they, alas, speak a Turkic language,
a language they got from Central Asia.
So maybe we ought to throw
them in with the Chinese.
You see the problem, that the
definition depends in part
on those a priori
perceptions you already have
of what race are and in part
on knowledge about linguistics
and in part on knowledge
about movements of people.
I'm gonna show you the result of a study,
the first one that I know
of that was done about this,
in which racial decisions were made
and essentially the world was divided up
into yellows, blacks,
browns, reds, and whites,
with a few extras.
The people of Southeast Asia were put
in a separate race.
The Oceanians of the Pacific
were put in a separate race.
I mean, something had to be
done, so that was what was done.
We have less problem deciding
whether people belong in
the same national group
or local group within
races, local population,
because we have linguistic definitions.
I mean, there are some
people who speak Italian,
some Irish, some English, some French,
and each one of those
linguistic groups is consistent.
We have Ewe and Kikuyu and and so on.
Those are put in separate groups.
And now we can ask the question,
how much of the known genetic variation,
of which there's a lot,
falls between two individuals both of whom
came from Isle de France?
How much of it falls
between French people,
Italians, Germans, Swedes, and so on,
and then how much of it is
between Europeans on the one hand
and Africans, sub-Saharan
Africans on the other.
So we can break down the variation
to within local populations,
between populations belonging
to the same so-called race,
and between races.
And when that study was done,
the result looked like the next slide.
At the time this study was done,
worldwide information existed.
I mean, this study had to depend
on the literature of science.
Worldwide information existed
for these bunch of genes.
They're a mixture of human blood groups
and various enzyme proteins.
We needn't concern
ourselves of what they are.
And then the question was asked
of all the variation
within the human species
for a particular gene, like the HP gene,
how much of it, what
proportion of that variation
occurs within local populations,
within Zulu, within Italians
within Han Chinese, and so on.
How much of it is between populations,
between Japanese and Chinese,
between Ewe and Kikuyu,
between Toba and bloods,
between Sioux and Yakuts, and so on.
And the answer, for example, for HP
was that 89% occurred within populations,
5% occurred between populations
within what we would call a race,
and only 5 1/2% percent
occurred between black,
white, yellow, brown, red and the others.
Is this clear to people
what's being done here?
The total variation is being divided up
in these three categories.
And if you do that for all the cases,
and I won't go through all these,
they're just a bunch of
numbers, the grand average,
which you may not be able to
see in the back of the room,
is that 85.4% of all
human genetic variation
then known by these genetic techniques,
85.4% occurs among individuals belonging
to the same linguistic local group
on the average overall groups,
within the Yakuts, within the English,
within the Icelanders,
within the Zulu, and so on.
Is that clear?
85%.
A further 8% in this study fell between
linguistic groups within
what we would call a race,
between Italians, French, Germans,
between Zulu and Ewe and Kikuyu.
And only 6% fell between
these major races.
Now you do appreciate that
although this number here
doesn't depend on how you define races,
the split between these two does depend
on how you define races,
which group you put in which race
and which group you don't.
But 85% of that variation falls within.
Now this study comes from
the Pleistocene of science.
I mean, it was done when we knew nothing
about DNA sequences and so on,
and it's entirely conceivable
that when the thing is updated
and people actually look at DNA sequences
that the answer will be quite different.
I want to show you the
result of the studies
of Dr. Barbujani on
DNA sequences in humans
which are not identified
by any particular genes.
We don't know what they do,
they're just chunks of DNA
plunked for various reasons
out of the human genome.
A huge number of numbers.
Ignore 'em.
Forget the details.
Just believe what I tell you.
(audience laughing)
Here's the name of all
of these little bits
and pieces of DNA which are recognized
by the techniques of DNA hybridization.
Forget about what they,
nobody knows what they do anyway.
They don't do anything,
they're just genetic variation.
And here is his list of the
percent of the variation
for these different ones
that fall within groups,
and these are not the same as
the genes I just showed you.
The total answer comes out to be 84 1/2%.
That's pretty close.
In fact, that's closer than any scientist
is entitled to expect.
Remember the previous result was 85.4.
Barbujani's result is 84.5.
He got the two last numbers confused.
But when he then asked how much is within,
he called it within continents
and that meant that he
had a particular way
of dividing populations
belonging to the same
or different races which was different
from the previous study.
He only got 4% between
groups within a race
and 11.7, about 12% between races.
So his between races
was about twice as much
as the previous study,
but the within group variation
as opposed to the between group variation
was identical with the previous study.
85% within and 15% between,
and depending on how you
decide who goes in what race,
you get more or less these two categories.
In fact, a number of such
studies have been done,
and let me show you all of them.
That's the next slide.
The number of studies being four. (laughs)
It's pretty remarkable, it really is.
I've never seen a scientific
result as clear as this,
a numerical scientific
result as clear as this.
Here are the four studies,
the first one based on proteins
is the one I showed you originally.
There's another one by Barry Latterton,
and then one on proteins and a DNA study.
And look at that, 85.4, 83.8, 86.
But you know, the point is
made, thank you very much,
that 85% of the variation
is already present
in all the people who are like us.
And only 15% are someplace else,
and some fraction of
that, between 3% and 8%,
is people who we think are like us anyway.
I mean, sure, they might
be Swedes and we're Danes,
but we don't make that distinction,
or between French and Irish.
And only something on
the order of 6% to 10%
lies between them, the ones
who all look alike, and us.
Now that's a fact of life,
and that's a fact with
which one has to cope,
that there is a strong
contradiction or disagreement
between our perception of
a lot of variation with us
and no variation in them,
with the observation that they're
just as variable as we are
and the differences between us and them
are pretty small on the
average genetically.
I want to depart from
these results for a moment
to say that doesn't mean
that there are no genes
which are found in some mutations
which are found in high
frequency in some groups
and not in others.
We all know that Tay-Sachs disease
is in very high frequency
among Ashkenazi Jews
and is essentially missing
in many other groups.
That's a special mutation
which has risen in frequency
for some reason we don't understand.
We have guesses about it
but we don't really know.
Or the famous case of sickle cell anemia
which is essentially unknown in Finland
but is very common in
Mediterranean groups,
not just African groups, by the way,
but Mediterranean and and
East Indian groups as well.
Various forms of abnormal hemoglobin
are spread through the Mediterranean
and West African groups.
So it doesn't mean
that because there's 85% variation within
that you can't find occasional
genes which really do,
as I showed you in the very first slide
or second slide, the genes which are
highly differentiated between groups,
but they're not typical.
And we don't need all this
fancy data to know that
because we identify people of other races
by things that are genetic.
You know, skin pigment
differences are genetic.
What I'm trying to say
is that the differences
between those groups are only skin deep,
if I can put it that way.
And therefore any claim, and
this is the important point,
any claim that because
there are patent differences
in skin color or height or hair form
or eye shape or something
between groups in different
parts of the world
that that implies that there are likely
to be differences in genes that matter
to any sensible person,
genes that contribute to our ability
to solve mathematical equations
or to be nice to other people
or something like that,
if such genes exist.
But that carryover cannot be made
because the genes that are very different
are the exception rather than the rule.
That doesn't prove, and I have to say
to avoid a question that
someone will ask me,
that doesn't prove that
there isn't a gene someplace,
nobody's ever found it,
that might influence your
charitable instincts,
and that maybe people in Africa
have a much higher frequency of that gene
than people in England.
That could be, but nobody's ever found it
and there's no reason to
think that such things exist.
So those are the facts about
human genetic variation,
that tremendous variation,
almost all of it within any local group.
And the question we have to ask is
how come how does that come to be
in the face of the fact
that there are some obvious
physical differences between people
in different parts of the world,
skin color for example,
hair form, and so on.
And that means we have
to ask about the forces
that operate on genetic differences
between and within groups.
The first thing I want to show you
is that most of the extreme
differences that we know of
where there's a very low
frequency of one form
of a gene in one group
and a very high frequency
of another form in another group,
most of them are between
small isolated populations,
hunters and gatherers or
people living in jungle regions
or something like that.
They're not between the
main body of West Africans
and the main body of Europeans.
That's not true for
everything, but this is a list,
and we're not gonna go down the list
but notice that, for example,
for this gene phosphoglucomutase
the lowest frequency of that gene
is known among Habana Jews
and the highest, which
is a very small group,
and the highest frequency
among the Yanomami Indians.
Take another one.
Here's NS, it's a blood
group type and secretor type.
5% is the extreme low value in the Navajo
and 65% in Palawans.
Zero in Luo, 96% in Papuans.
Ainu appear, Basques appear,
Blood Indians appear,
Chenchu, Eskimo, Dyaks,
people of the Yucatan,
people on Tristan da Cunha, and so on.
Over and over again the
names of these groups,
which are at one extreme or
another of the genetic variation
are names of small groups
living in out-of-the-way places
fairly isolated from other groups.
And that's a very important observation,
that most of the genetic differences
are differences at the extreme.
If you think of all the
frequencies of genes
as sort of being clustered in a space,
then the ones on the outside of the ball,
the ones that are oddball
are these very small populations
isolated from one another, and
we have to understand that.
It's not always true.
You can find exceptions here,
but it is the general rule.
And the question is, why is that?
How come my list contains
all these oddball,
I mean, oddball in the
sense of of small groups
outside of our experience.
Part of the reason,
probably an important part
of the reason, we don't know.
By the way, we don't know the answer
because we don't know for example
how natural selection might
operate on these genes
to make Papuans have one form
and Luo have another form.
But probably the answer
has to do with the fact
that they are very small in numbers,
and when populations are
very small in numbers
then they differentiate from one another
in the kinds of genes
they have by sheer chance.
Let me show you one of the
most extreme cases I know.
This is really a very striking case.
This is a genetic type that people use
in forensic uses of DNA.
They say, oh, your honor,
the probability that the person on trial
did not commit the crime
is one in 4,327,256
because we know that because
we looked at his DNA.
This is one of those DNA differences
that are used for that,
and I wanted to call your attention
to the frequency distribution of the nine
different kinds known in two populations,
the Karitiana which are 97% number one
and 3% number six and don't
have any of the others
as compared to the Surui who
have 56% of one and 14%
of two 14% of seven,
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Who are the Karitiana and the Surui?
They are two Brazilian
Indian forest-dwelling groups
living within 500 miles of each other
and they are as extremely
different as you can get
with respect to this gene.
How did that happen?
They're even linguistically
separated from one another.
So somehow in the history of the evolution
of these groups they have become
extraordinarily divergent.
It's be hard to make the case, I think,
that natural selection favored number one
in the Karitiana and number,
and something else in the Surui,
but I suppose it's possible.
But the answer is almost certainly
a consequence of the small
size of the breeding group,
and the way it works is as follows.
You have a very small number of people
who represent the breeding population.
Some of those people have no children,
some have one, some have
two, some have three.
Moreover, if I have two
different forms of a gene,
half of my sperm have one form
and half of 'em have the other,
and if I only have one
kid that kid will have
one or the other but it
can't have both of them.
So the result of that
is that every generation
there's a kind of sampling process,
like tossing a coin by chance.
And that means if you
start out a population
with 50/50 of two forms,
the next generation made up of 27 people
or 420 or even a 1,000 will
not have exactly 50/50.
They may be 48 to 52 or even 45 to 55.
Well, what about the
generation after that?
Well, they don't tend to go back.
There's no law of averages,
because they started
out with 45% of one type
and 55% of the other
so the next generation
makes a sample from that,
and it's what's known in our
field as a drunkards walk.
That is, say, what happens
if the frequency of the gene
goes from zero over
there to one over there,
then the frequency of the
thing every generation
takes random steps back
and forth like this,
and if you wait long enough
it falls off the platform
on one side or the other.
That is, say everybody
has one kind or the other,
but some groups will have one kind
and other drunkards will fall over there.
And that's what's known as the process
of random genetic drift.
And all populations and all genes
are subject to this phenomenon,
but a very small population is obviously
much more subject to it
than a very big population.
So we expect indeed that
very small populations
will tend to be outliers.
They will be more drunken, if you like,
in this random walk, and will be closer
to one of the edge points than others.
And that is a very important factor
in the differentiation of groups.
So even though it's
true that a fair amount
of genetic variation
occurs between populations
and between major groups,
that is not the same as saying
that those differences
arose for functional
and natural selective reasons
because this population ought to have that
and the other population
ought to have that.
A good part of that
variation between groups
is sheer chance,
and I must emphasize that
because you don't want to make too much
of the variation of the
differences that do exist.
The other feature which we
have to take into account,
the very important feature
we have to take into account
in trying to understand
the origins of variations
have to do with the fact
that human populations
have been migrating, slave-taking, raping,
carrying off other populations
presumably in prehistoric time
and certainly in all historical time.
Let me say a brief word
about the Icelanders.
Some of you have heard
that some people in Iceland
claim that Icelanders are
more genetically homogeneous
than anybody else in the
world, and why is that?
Because Iceland was founded
by a few hardy Vikings
and after that all the breeding
occurred within Iceland
and no foreign genes came
in, and therefore Iceland,
everybody is related to everybody
and therefore that would be very good for,
I don't know, some medical
purpose that I can't fathom.
But the reason I haven't
tried to fathom it
is because it happens to be untrue.
If you look at these data
about genetic variation
of all these kinds for Icelanders,
they turn out to be, roughly speaking,
as variable as Norwegians,
English, Scottish,
Danes, and so on, and indeed they fall
right down in the middle of all Europeans.
I mean, they're far from
being the most homogeneous
of all Europeans.
They are sort of in the middle someplace.
They're nothing special.
And why is that?
Because if you, and as every geneticist,
human geneticist should do,
if you read the Sagas,
the Icelandic Sagas,
you will discover that the
Icelanders made a living
exactly, the Icelandic Vikings
made a living exactly the way
the classical Greeks made a living,
namely they were farmers half the year
and the other half the
year they were pirates.
They got on their boats
and they went off raiding.
And when you raided, you just
didn't take money and things,
you took girls, too.
And there were slaves in Iceland.
Those slaves came from Russia,
they came from Scotland,
they came from all over the North Sea.
There was a tremendous
amount of slave-taking
and a tremendous amount
of the sort of thing
you expect from pirates.
And the consequence of that is
that the Icelandic population
is as heterogeneous as any,
genetically heterogeneous
as any population in Europe.
Indeed, you can trace that.
I should take a cultural detour here.
I do urge you, those of
you who are interested
in the subject, to read the Sagas.
They're a real eye-opener.
If you look at place names
around the northern border of Scotland,
the northern 1/3 of the Scottish coast,
you will discover a lot of place names
that have the word ness
in them like Lochness
and Inverness and so on.
Ness is the Icelandic word for cape,
and it's the capes on
which these pirates landed
and set up little settlements.
So northern Scotland is as
Icelandic as it is anything else.
And it's extremely
important to understand,
I tell the story in some detail
because this is the
story of human movement
and mating and so on,
a lot of moving around,
a lot of taking of captives, of slaves,
of rape, of all that kinda,
and it's gone on all over the world.
I mean, you might like to think
that Europeans invented
slavery, but they didn't.
Now I want to show you, for example,
the effect of cross group
mating in the United States.
We have a fairly good idea
from this FY blood group
that I showed you, which
is highly differentiated
between Africans and Europeans,
of how much mating has occurred
between Africans in North
America brought over as slaves
and their European masters,
or more recently between
Africans in urban areas
and Europeans in urban areas.
There's a history of
mating that's occurred
between these two groups,
and we have a fairly good
notion of how much that is.
Our estimate based on this gene
that happens to be highly differentiated
between Africans and Europeans
is that among people
who classify themselves
as Afro-Americans or Blacks,
at that time they were
classified as Blacks,
the proportion of their
European ancestry was 19%.
Among those who live
in Detroit it was 26%.
Among those in Oakland,
California it was 22%.
Among the people in
Charleston, South Carolina
it was only 4%.
And in Evans and Bulloch
counties in Georgia,
rural counties, it was 11%.
So that gives you some notion of how much
intermixture has gone on.
Various people who are
classified as Afro-American
have various amounts of European
and American Indian
ancestry, but on the average
in the larger cities of the United States
people have something like
20% to 25% European ancestry.
And that's only been
going on in large amount
presumably since the
beginning of the 19th century,
or perhaps a little earlier.
So the rate of infiltration of genes
from one group into another
where the groups themselves still maintain
some kind of arbitrary
racial classification,
and that's important.
Look, this is an underestimate
because it's only the
people who report themselves
as being African American.
How about all the people in this room
who don't report themselves
as being African American,
but like Pushkin have
an African grandfather
or great-grandfather.
Pushkin was a great guy.
Alexander Pushkin's great-grandfather
was a famous general, Russian general,
who was, in fact, an African,
who was a kind of Russian Othello.
He became a very important
person in the Russian military.
Pushkin would not have
reported himself as black,
but 1/8 of his genes came from Africa.
And that's important to understand that.
Okay, you don't have to see the numbers.
So you have fusion of populations
but you also have, on
the the other face of it,
a tremendous amount of local marriages
and staying where you are,
and you also have the effect of migrations
and of conquests like the Icelanders
which leave their genetic trace in places
where they came in.
And we could look at the next picture,
that first map which is supposed to be
of the British Isles.
It is.
You will notice that migration also occurs
by continental drift because in the north
of the British Isles is Kyushu.
I don't know.
I don't know how Kyushu got
just to the north of Scotland.
but there it is.
(audience laughing)
Please ignore it.
You'll see Kyushu on another slide.
This is a map of the frequencies
of the blood group, A,
ordinary blood group A,
in different parts of
England and Scotland.
I don't know if you can see
it at the back of the room
but the average frequency
in northern Scotland
is 31% of type A.
It gets down to be 35%, 39%,
down to greater and greater.
And just off the east
coast of England it is 46%.
Now England, as you
know, is one of the most,
as they used to say, bastardized
countries in the world.
It is a consequence of invasions
from Denmark and Saxony, from France,
from the north of Vikings and so on,
and what has happened is
that where the invaders land
they leave their genes, quite locally,
and even though those
invaders no longer arrived
after the 11th century,
the last time there was
serious invasions of England
was the 11th century, their
genes have stayed around.
And if you look, this part
of England which is called,
I don't know how you
pronounce it in English,
Dane-law or Dan-a-law,
Danelaw, which has a lot of
Danish place names and so on,
has Danish blood group frequencies.
And this part has Pictish
and Gaelic blood group frequencies.
And Ireland, which is not shown
in here, is quite different.
However you notice 37.6 right
here, that's like Ireland.
Why is that?
Because that's where Liverpool is
and that's where large
numbers of Irish immigrants
arrive still into Britain.
So despite the fact,
and I was talking to
Monty Slatkin about this,
I was puzzled by it but he, I think,
gave me the right answer.
Despite the fact that England
has, since the 17th century,
since the acts of enclosure,
the first acts of enclosure,
had a huge amount of migration of people
into cities from the countryside,
the ones that are left behind,
see, Liverpool does influence this
but London apparently not much.
The ones that are left
behind in the country
are the descendants of those invaders
or the Picts who were pushed north
or the Danes who came in
and so on and so forth.
So still to this day Britain shows
the history of invasions
of more than 1,000 years ago.
Now that's not only true of Britain.
The other extremely industrialized country
for which this is true is Japan.
There's Hokkaido, Honshu,
Shikoku, and Kyushu
and here's the Korean Peninsula,
and this is the frequency of
the blood group A in Japan
which is about 24% in Hokkaido
among the Ainu and Japanese in Hokkaido,
and reaches a maximum
of more than 30% here.
This cline in frequencies is maintained
despite the fact that Japan
is highly industrialized
and that great deal of movement
because of people who stay behind.
But this is much more ancient in some ways
and more recent in others
than the English situation.
I call your attention to this cluster here
across the Straits of Tsushima from Korea,
which has this gene frequency
which is like the Korean gene frequency.
People living across the
Straits of Tsushima from Korea,
in Kyushu and and southern Honshu,
have gene frequencies like the Koreans.
Why is that?
Because there were repeated invasions
of the Japanese archipelago from Korea
over and over again by the Chinese,
by the mainland Chinese.
And the last of those
invasions occurred in the,
somebody's gonna tell
me I'm wrong about this
but I'm gonna say the 15th century,
and that last attempted
invasion was in the 15th century
but it didn't work.
Why?
Because the invasion fleet
which was leaving Korea to arrive in Japan
was blown away by a huge tropical storm
which was called the wind of the gods,
which in Japanese is kamikaze.
So the first famous
kamikaze got rid of that
and the Chinese never tried it again.
Nevertheless, since the 15th century
that differentiation has remained
and is probably the historic,
the longtime history of Japan
with northern Aborigines here
and mainland Asians here fusing together
to form the modern Japanese population
and the cline still shows.
So what I'm trying to emphasize to you
is if you want to understand
the genetic differentiation between people
you have to understand that
a constant feature of it
has been invasions from
one place to another,
cross mating, and the world
is a kind of hodgepodge made of that.
And the last picture I'm gonna show
is a very abstract picture which I cannot
possibly explain to you correctly.
It's an attempt to
summarize everything we know
about gene frequency
differences all in one number.
It's called a principal component,
and maybe a few of you, like Leo Goodman,
know what that means, but I'm
not gonna try to explain it.
It's a way of combining the numbers
from all the different
genes in an optimal way.
And what this shows is the
value, roughly speaking,
of that principal component
of human variation
in Africa, Europe, coming
across Europe this way,
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and being smallest in Asia.
That's the so-called
first principal component.
And what it reveals is the
big picture of migration
in the Eastern Hemisphere.
Well, in the world, in fact.
You had a northward spread
from Africa into Europe
so the European gene,
the European gene frequencies
in their principal component
are most like Africa.
I know that'll be very
alarming to some Europeans,
but there it is.
The Slavs are somewhat less Africanized,
and then when you get into Central Asia
it changes somewhat,
and then you get into central, the steps,
when you get into Central
Asia it moves again.
Australian Aborigines
are off by themselves,
and then these Asians,
these Siberians moved into the new world
and moved south and so on.
This is a picture of the general migration
of people from prehistoric times
perhaps, from the origin
of humans in Africa.
So if you want to understand,
and now you have to tell me,
where are the racial boundaries?
Well, if I use principal components
then of course all the Africans
and their English and French
masters belong to one race.
The people of Central
Europe belong to another
and so on and so forth.
Which doesn't, of course,
correspond to what you ordinarily think.
So my final point is that
human genetic variation,
we can get rid of that last slide, Ellen.
The human genetic variation
is the consequence
of a long history of migration,
of cross mating, of
piracy, of slave-taking.
You know, by the way, I'll just
make a parenthetical remark.
If you read Henry M. Stanley's journal
of how he found Livingstone in Africa,
you find that as he moved
across from the coast
to Lake Victoria, he
passed through one town.
He didn't hack his way
through any jungles.
He walked on a road,
and that road passed
through a lot of towns.
And the chief in those
towns was always called
the Sheikh because, of course, the Arabs
had been there long since
and they had left behind not only culture
but genes as well.
East Africa is very much Arabized,
at least in Henry M. Stanley's time.
So the picture you have to have
is of a mobile species
moving from its origin
throughout the world, occupying the world,
and in the process by mercantile movement,
by slave-taking and so
on, mixing things up,
leaving behind some variation
whose origin we don't really understand.
I mean, I don't know why
people in West Africa
have dark skins and people
in Finland have light skins.
Don't believe the stories.
And I wanna end this,
don't believe the stories
that, well, it's because if you're in,
in the far north you don't get much UV.
If you don't get enough
UV you'll have rickets,
so it's better to have
the lightest possible skin
so you get as much
ultraviolet as possible.
Whereas if you live in darkest Africa,
why, you might get skin cancer
if you didn't filter
out all that sunlight,
so natural selection's
made your skin dark.
Those stories don't work
for a variety of reasons.
One is because even
the most avid sun lover
of the Los Angeles beaches
who finally gets skin cancer
from constantly being irradiated
generally gets that skin cancer
after reproductive years.
It's not a serious issue
in reproductive rates.
And as far as UV is
concerned in the far north,
it's not clear to me that
if some people got rickets
that had any effect on the
reproductive rate at all.
The most fertile mouse I ever worked with
when I used to work with mice
was a so-called paralytic mouse,
a male who could barely
get himself around.
So those stories are easy to tell
but we have no evidence about them.
My best guess is that the
differences in skin color,
hair form, eye shape and so on
are a consequence of Darwin's notion,
a notion that Darwin had
and that of so-called sexual selection,
that for one accidental
historical reason or another
the person who was darkest
in skin in your place
seemed most powerful and most attractive
and became the model for beauty,
whereas someplace else
it was some other oddball
morphological feature.
And the consequence is that
there is by reduplication of that
a buildup of differentiation based on
who wants to have, mate with whom.
Now that's just a guess.
I don't know.
But none of those natural
selection stories work,
and I think you should abolish
them from your notions.
We do not know why the
skin-deep, superficial,
minority differences in genes
that do exist between major
geographical regions exist.
We don't even know where the
genes for skin color are.
Nobody's ever found them.
I mean, they're there
somewhere, but we don't know.
Okay, so let me then end by saying that
although race is unquestionably a reality,
a social reality in
every place in the world,
it is not a very good biological reality.
It doesn't make sense biologically.
It's not the way a systematist would want
to divide up the species,
if they are sensible.
It is rather an excuse
for a social reality
and an attempt to prove
that that social reality
must also correspond to deep
and important differences,
some of which are appearing on the surface
but most of which are
inside and important,
and the evidence is against that.
And so I think you need
to reject the notion
that race is a sensible
biological concept for humans.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
And again, I apologize
for all the numbers.
If there are questions,
Ellen has said that you must
come up to this microphone
and ask the question.
- [Audience Member] So
what is the latest status
of Out of Africa theory and
multiregional hypothesis?
Which one has more evidence?
- The latest status of
the Out of Africa theory.
Well, there's a general
consensus that that's right
and this components
analysis that I showed you
underpins that, so I'd say that's right.
It's a big difference between saying
that's the general consensus
of people who work in the field
and saying that it's somehow
proven as the night, the day.
That's another issue, but
that's the general status, yes.
To answer about Out of Africa,
I should make a remark.
I believe that human ancestors originally
differentiating came out of Africa,
but I haven't the faintest
idea what they looked like.
Look, it's very important.
They may have come Out of Africa
but that doesn't say they were black.
For all I know they looked like Arabs,
or they looked like
something we've never seen.
I mean, we don't have the faintest idea
what they looked like,
because if the theory
of sexual selection is right,
this differentiation of skin
color and hair form and so on
is something that occurred subsequently
or during the process,
and tells us nothing
about what our Aboriginal
ancestors looked like.
But they did apparently
come Out of Africa, yes.
- [Audience Member] One more.
I was watching Journey of
Man by Dr. Spencer Wells.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] So according to him
there is this group of Kalihari Bushmen
who are supposed to be the original group.
So what do you think,
what's your take on that?
- Well, I don't have a
professional opinion on that.
I should confess that Spencer Wells
was my graduate student,
and therefore I'm not perhaps capable
of giving an objective opinion.
(audience laughing)
I'll say nothing more than that.
Don't get the wrong idea.
But the Kalahari people
are a special case,
are a kind of special case
which we have to be very cautious of.
Most of the people like the Kalahari
are people who apparently
have been pushed out
by more powerful groups from
a different sort of life,
and marginalized, and
live a marginal existence.
That was almost certainly true
for the people of Patagonia,
of the extreme south around Cape Horn,
of the Kalahari, indeed of the Berbers,
the desert-dwelling, pastoral
people of the Near EAst
who, if one believes Ibn Khaldun,
were repeatedly extruded
and then conquered
and then extruded and conquered.
So I'm rather loath to come to conclusions
about evolution from groups
who have been somewhat recently,
we don't know how recently,
were originally part of another population
and then shoved out in small numbers.
I think it's dangerous to make
too many conclusions from that, okay?
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- [Audience Member] In your final slide,
the upper map was principal component one
that is consistent with the
Out of Africa hypothesis,
but the lower map, I'm wondering
if that's principal component two.
- It is.
- [Audience Member] And I'm wondering that
there was a line across
Africa at the Sahara,
there's a line across
Eurasia at the Urals,
and that would seem to suggest
that the primary signal
in human genetics is out of Africa
and the colonization of the planet.
But the next strongest signal
is the regional differentiation?
- Absolutely, I mean you're
quite right about that.
For this particular
purpose I can't go into
the difference between the first
and the second principal component,
but what you say I think
people should listen to.
- [Audience Member] All right.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] You may be familiar
with the Affymetrix GeneChip platform.
Are you familiar with any new studies
that look at gene expression analysis
on top of just gene differentiation?
- No, I'm not, I'm sorry.
I mean, I'm familiar with
the Affymetrix GeneChip
but perhaps you want to
say something about that.
- [Audience Member] No, do you feel
knowing about that technology,
do you think that that may reveal
more information about this subject?
- Well, the trouble with gene expression
is that expression patterns are embedded
in a network of signaling,
of expression signaling
which would be very difficult
to interpret in the way we need to.
That is, say, we might have a
different expression pattern
in one group than another
because one gene is being
expressed differently
and that's having a downstream effect
on the expression of others.
So I'm not saying that expression patterns
will not be of any interest,
but I think their
interpretation is subject
to the serious complexity
of the patterns of expression induction.
And I don't know exactly
how to interpret them
is the problem.
For example, I don't know,
somebody can tell us
because they could look,
what the effect on gene
expression patterns
of all kinds is of people who have,
say, sickle cell anemia as opposed
to not sickle cell anemia.
Does that have consequences in other parts
of the gene expression pattern?
I don't know the answer.
You could find out.
But I think one has to do that
because of the epistatic interactions
between gene expression patterns.
That's the best I can say.
- [Audience Member] Hi, I thought
the sexual selection story
that you gave at the end
was very interesting.
I had never heard that before with people.
And I was wondering what you think
would be an ideal test to test
the sexual selection story
versus a non-sexual
natural selection story
such as the one that you mentioned
about vitamin D and cancer,
short of time travel.
- I don't know the
answer to that question.
Monty, have you got an answer to that?
How I could distinguish sexual selection
from what we usually
call natural selection?
It doesn't seem obvious to me
because the difference
is not a statistical
or mechanical difference,
it's a difference in causation
which has the same influence on the fact
that some types have more
offspring than others
and the various statistical tests one does
doesn't ask why do some types
have more offspring than others,
it only presents evidence that some types
do have more offspring than others.
The differentiation natural selection
and sexual selection is
in the engineering story
you'd tell, and that's
a physiological story
which is not revealed by
patterns of gene frequency.
So I guess the reason that even Monty
can't answer it is because
it doesn't have an answer.
No, no, I'm serious about that.
I mean, you have to understand
that sexual selection
does not differ in its dynamics from,
or kinetics from other kinds of selection.
It's just a different
kind of causal story.
It still lines up that some people
have a lot more offspring than others,
and certain genotypes have
more offspring than others.
- [Audience Member] Two questions.
First, what is your
perspective on hybrid vigor?
And secondly, what do you think about
this whole idea of they're not,
the surface meaning does
not have this deeper meaning
and what are the implications for--
- I'm sorry, what was the second question?
- [Audience Member] The whole idea about
the surface differences really don't have
these deeper meanings that we sometimes
in the lay public apply to them,
and how do you speculate your information?
What effect do you think it will have
on the lay public, which sometimes care,
want to perpetuate this notion
of racial prejudice and so forth?
- Well, the answer to the first one
as far as hybrid vigor is concerned,
there's no evidence of hybrid vigor.
Indeed, there's no evidence
of hybrid vigor in corn.
I mean, I could give a whole lecture
on the nonsense about
hybrid vigor in corn.
The hybridization in corn is a gimmick
to guarantee property
rights to seed companies.
We could produce corn as productive
as hybrid corn by mass selection.
That's well known, that's not a problem.
So to try to carry over
the claim of hybrid vigor
from corn to people, if
that's what you're asking,
whether people who are
the result of matings
between distant groups
will somehow be better,
we have no proof it couldn't exist
but we have no evidence for it.
Now one thing that does
happen is if you mate
between people who have as differentiated
gene groups as possible,
you may cover up certain
deleterious recessive genes.
That may happen, but I don't think
that's what you're really asking.
And one more.
No, no, let me finish my answer to her.
As far as what effect
this has on the attitudes
of people toward superiority
of one race or another,
it's not clear it has any effect
because, as I said, the fact
that 85% of the variation
is within a local group
and so little of it between
doesn't prove that the
genes that really matter
are highly differentiated between groups.
I could always say, yeah but what about
that small percent?
You haven't told me
about the genes for IQ,
the genes for charity, and if I want
for some ideological reason to claim
that there are those, I haven't
proved they don't exist.
So I think data like these
in large part predispose
one toward an understanding
of the situation, but if
you're a hardcore racist
they're not gonna have any effect at all.
- [Audience Member] Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)